[Música]
e
hola como estan sabían ustedes que en
méxico existen más de 243.000 escuelas
públicas en todo el país y que estas
escuelas albergan a más de 27.5 millones
de alumnos para que se den una idea esto
es 1.5 veces la población total de chile
en el ciclo escolar de 2017 18 del
presupuesto de gasto federal de la
totalidad el 17 por ciento se aplicó a
educación de este presupuesto el 98.5
fue para gasto corriente y únicamente el
1.7 para gasto de capital en castellano
qué significa esto pues muy sencillo de
cada peso que se invirtió en este ciclo
escolar única y exclusivamente menos de
2 centavos se aplicaron a
infraestructura educativa nueva ya
mejorar nuestras escuelas
y después nos preguntamos por qué las
condiciones de las escuelas de nuestro
país son estas y también los niveles de
bajo rendimiento que tienen nuestros
alumnos
buenas noches ese niño de hong que ven
ahí soy yo gustavo lara alcántara soy el
menor de tres hermanos soy de maíz
hueles que en su momento estudiaron en
escuelas como usted como las que ustedes
vieron ahí pero al paso del tiempo
cuando tuvieron la oportunidad de ser
funcionarios públicos se preocuparon por
generar nueva infraestructura educativa
en el estado y también de mejorar la que
se tenía
ellos son mis compañeros de quinto año
de la escuela primaria el licenciado
gustavo díaz ordaz que muy posiblemente
algunos de ustedes estudiaron en ella y
se encuentra esta escuela ubicada en la
colonia morelos aquí en toluca
déjenme platicarles una historia que muy
posiblemente pudiera ser un modelo
replicable para poder mejorar la
infraestructura de nuestras escuelas en
todo el país
ellos son mis compañeros ya un poco más
creciditos
gonzalo toledo que está sentado atrás de
mí es un compañero y amigo que tenía más
de 38 años de no tener contacto con él
y a raíz de que jaime maldonado un
compañero también muy querido falleció
hace dos años
lo que hicimos fue lo que hice fue
tratar de localizar a gonzalo porque
cuando pase el tiempo cuántos de
nosotros hemos dejado de tener contacto
con nuestros amigos del kinder de la
primaria y la secundaria lo único que no
retoña que no encontramos es la muerte
por esto me dice gonzalo oye gustamos
qué te parece si haces una comida nos
juntamos los compañeros y vemos qué es
lo que ha pasado en lo de nuestra vida y
como siempre en este tipo de comidas la
pregunta es te casaste sigue soltero te
divorcias te cuántos hijos tienes que
estudiantes etcétera etcétera y aquí
sigue la siguiente etapa nos empezamos a
quejar por la situación económica y
política y muchas veces social qué está
pasando en nuestro país
lo que hicimos en esta comida al final
fue decir parent vamos a dejar de
quejarnos y qué les parece si en lugar
de estar comentando todos estos temas
echamos manos a la obra y hacemos algún
tipo de obra social el doctor jorge
muñoz que está de blanco ahí dicen bueno
si nos estamos reuniendo
y lo que nos vincula es nuestra primaria
porque no regresar y ver en qué
condiciones está ver si necesita algo y
podernos reunirnos todos entornos de
nuestra querida primaria y así lo
hicimos y como siempre el que genera la
idea se le carga el muerto
le dijimos muy bien mi querido muñoz in
lo que tendrás que hacer es ir a la
escuela y ver si el director nos quiere
recibir y en base a eso veremos qué es
lo que sale y efectivamente el director
de la escuela el maestro efrén nos
recibió de una manera muy calurosa
caminamos por los pasillos que en su
momento cuando éramos niños los veíamos
inmensos ahora los veíamos muy pequeños
y en esa travesía fuimos dando cuenta
que les necesitaba mejoría de jardinería
cambio de puertas mejorar la pintura y
también nos llevaron a nuestro auditorio
que en ese momento recordamos que cuando
nosotros éramos alumnos de 3º se había
inaugurado nos había tocado nuevo ese
auditorio y por último el maestro friend
nos dice ojalá y también nos pudieran
ayudar con la ha duplicado ahora porque
para nosotros es muy importante
para esto le dije que le parece maestro
frente si aprovechando que cumplimos
este año 40 años de haber regresado
somos de la generación 72 78 hace usted
una ceremonia y después hacemos una
convivencia y ahí nos hace el
planteamiento de las necesidades de la
escuela dijo perfecto y manos a la obra
en ese momento
lo que se hizo fue planear cada uno de
los dos eventos con la ayuda de todos
los compañeros en ese momento en la
reunión lo que hicimos fue establecer
comisiones voluntarias de las cuales
cinco de nuestros compañeros tomaron la
titularidad de cada una de ellas y el
resto se fueron sumando de manera
voluntaria
ya teníamos el reto ahora lo más
importante cómo hacerlo teníamos que ver
cada uno de nosotros como pudiéramos
participar para poder conseguir los
recursos económicos la mano de obra
buscar vincularnos con diferentes
instituciones y lo más importante no
perder la emoción que teníamos cada uno
de nuestros compañeros por poderles
hacer un regalo a nuestra escuela
y así arrancamos el primer tema fue la
jardinería y como ustedes podrán ver se
encontraba en esas condiciones y después
de trabajo arduo pudimos lograr que
llegara a tener la escuela y nuestros
jardines en esas condiciones
1600 plantas que se vieron donadas los
floricultores del norte del estado no
los donaron con muchísimo gusto más el
trabajo de padres de familia maestros
alumnos de la escuela y ex alumnos
sumado a jardineros que el municipio nos
hizo favor de apoyarnos pudimos lograr
lo que ustedes vieron el otro tema las
puertas de la escuela yo les puedo
asegurar que esa puerta que ven ustedes
allí tiene los 47 años que tiene nuestra
escuela de fundada
y hasta un poco cansada y pues la idea
era ver la posibilidad de poder cambiar
las puertas y con el trabajo de
compañeros y ex alumnos de toda la
escuela
pudimos cambiarlas y ver cuáles son las
nuevas puertas que se lograron 28
puertas todas las escuelas todas las
puertas de los salones con la
cooperación económica de compañeros el
trabajo de padres de familia maestros ex
alumnos y carpinteros porque obviamente
los que trabajamos y participamos en
esto de carpintería no sabíamos
absolutamente nada logramos el objetivo
el siguiente punto el color y la pintura
de nuestra escuela no era fácil
pintar una escuela implica conseguir
muchos litros de pintura
lo que hicimos fue
acceder al diputado local más el apoyo
de compañeros que aportaron pintura
pudimos lograr obtener toda la pintura
para para poder pintar nuestra escuela
el siguiente punto era la famosa
duplicador algunos decían pero como
estas alturas seguimos imprimiendo
exámenes pues sí
1500 alumnos en dos turnos tiene nuestra
primaria obviamente para poder hacer los
exámenes necesitamos de papel
y la idea y el reto era poder obtener
los recursos para poder comprarla
duplicador y así se hizo con la
aportación del club de leones de metepec
y aportación también de compañeros y
aprovechando las rebajas del buen fin
pudimos obtener los suficientes recursos
para poder comprar la tan deseada
duplicado ahora
eso que ven ustedes allí
inicialmente lo podemos ver como basura
y posiblemente así pudo haber terminado
sin embargo con el apoyo y la donación
de la fundación cinépolis el trabajo del
personal de mantenimiento la aportación
de recursos de la sociedad de padres de
familia de la escuela y el trabajo de
maestros y alumnos
y poco a poco fuimos transformando
nuestro auditorio
y poco a poco fuimos cubriendo esas
necesidades que tenían
y de tener un auditorio con unas butacas
con 47 años de edad
pudimos transformar nuestro auditorio a
un auditorio de clase mundial se
cambiaron todas las lámparas
235 butacas las cortinas del auditorio y
se pintó lentamente
siempre pensamos que para poder realizar
un proyecto se necesita dinero y no
necesariamente lo que creo es que se
necesita voluntad y cariño para hacer
las cosas un proyecto que se hubiera
necesitado más de un millón de pesos
única y exclusivamente con aportaciones
menores al 10% se pudo lograr lo que
ustedes ya vieron
esos niños que hace 40 años tuvieron la
oportunidad de estrenar un auditorio y
de disfrutar una escuela prácticamente
nueva que han crecido lo que hemos
tenido y lo que logramos fue que a
través del corazón pudiéramos lograr el
hacer todas las actividades que nos
había pedido el director de la escuela
ahora estos niños 40 años después están
disfrutando al igual que nosotros en ese
momento
un auditorio nuevo
yo quisiera pedirles que se llevaran
esta tarde
algo para reflexionar si ustedes quieren
hacer cualquier tipo de actividad o
lograr una meta si ustedes utilizan o
llevan a cabo estas seis variables lo
podrán lograr primero hay que
capitalizar el entusiasmo de las
personas que quieran participar como fue
el caso de mis compañeros después hay
que establecer un objetivo que sea
alcanzable generar un liderazgo buscar
aliados que quieran sumarse a esa
iniciativa generar un compromiso que es
algo muy importante
mis padres decían todo lo que empiezas
tienes que terminarlo y por último lo
más importante ponerle amor a las cosas
si le ponemos amor a cada una de las
actividades que hacemos la realidad es
que vamos a terminar concluyendo lo que
hacemos me gustaría terminar con esta
frase que engloba lo que hicimos durante
este tiempo solos pudiéramos haber ido
más rápido pero trabajando juntos
podemos llegar
más lejos
ellos mis compañeros todos anudados
todos viendo por un mismo objetivo
lograron alcanzar la meta de arreglar su
escuela quisiera pedirles a mis
compañeros que el día de hoy me hacen
favor de acompañarme se pongan de pie
para que todos les demos un fuerte
aplauso
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias